that everyone wishes for the american
dream and roots for you
for the american dream until it comes
through
[Music]
what's going on everyone happy uh
saturday
today um i uh wanted to make this
podcast
for you because i got off the phone
with uh ed turner and he and i had a
long conversation about a
wide breadth of topics and he's like
dude you should talk more about this
kind of stuff
and so what i want to do is actually
share with you
um kind of my experience of having the
chip on my shoulder
and kind of where it got me and what i
learned in the process and so
if you have any kind of like
thoughts around uh like trying to beat
someone and like
like you're gonna take these guys down
and like all this stuff and i know many
many people in this space uh you know
feel that way towards me
i can tell you having literally gone
through the entire process
um it's it's really interesting so like
when i when i had my gyms
i i wrote this huge essay and it was for
myself because i actually have a
creative writing background that
most people don't know about um but i
entitled it
uh that everyone wishes for the american
dream
and roots for you for the american dream
until it comes true and i felt that way
with my clients you know they were
rooting for me when i was
sleeping on the floor they're like good
for you like pursuing your dreams and
um but as time went on
you know and i started to be able to
hire people we started making more money
um and eventually i didn't have to work
in the business
they're like oh you're too good for us
now like oh a big businessman right
and everyone roots for you um until you
do better than them
and so what ends up happening is that
you have to set higher and higher goals
for yourself
to drive yourself right and for me i
uh definitely was an angrier person or
maybe i'm just better at hiding it now i
have no idea
um but i was definitely angrier about
stuff and
i set this goal that i was going to beat
pedro's
if you guys recall who badros kulian and
he's a big guru or was big guru in the
in the gym space uh he owns fit body and
and i i started telling myself all of
these things you know what i mean like
how
he's wronging people and he's ripping
people off and i would tell myself these
stories
you know what i mean to try and like get
myself amped up about like how i'm just
gonna like
write the industry and and do everything
and i'm gonna be bigger than him and
like all this stuff right
and the reality is um
you know as as time went on and and you
know jim lunch grew and
we grew and grew and grew and um you
know i'm not i don't know what his
numbers are but i'm fairly certain that
our coaching program
is and has been bigger than his in this
space at least
for a while and when i got there
um you know i guess to the higher you
know to to match that and surpass
um first off i found that it was
incredibly empty
but secondly i felt
and realized that he was completely
unaffected
he had he was still incredibly wealthy
he had other entrepreneurial endeavors
he was pursuing
um and this my success in no way
affected his life
and it was one of the most
humbling and also freeing moments of my
life when i realized that
because it he wasn't an enemy
i and i doubt i was even you know like a
blip on the radar
um during that time and i mean obviously
they know who we are now but
um it it didn't affect his life
and all this malicious you know list
this vengeance this vendetta
that i had like the only person it
poisoned was me
and you know there's two sides to this
coin on on one
side you have like the the drive
um you know if you guys have seen the
jordan documentary talks about how you
used to make things up that other people
would say about them that they never
actually said
and i feel like it's kind of like that
and it's and that chip on your shoulder
does drive you so i can't say it didn't
drive me
but i don't think it made me a happier
person
and so and believe me i'm not the guy
who's like go go hug trees and be happy
like
i'm all about achieving uh achieving
stuff so like by all means go do
whatever works for you
um but i can tell you that
it seeing it truly seeing my success
not in any way impact someone else's
success
really radically transformed my
feelings about competitors about the
space about the industry
about other coaches in general about
what i was willing to do to help other
coaches etc
it really transformed me um i
started calling up other people who were
in our space and just saying like hey
how can i help you grow
and they're like seriously and i was
like yeah man i'm like i mean you're not
gonna take my stuff
and i'm not gonna take your stuff
because people are attracted to
different people for different reasons
you know people like everyone has
different psychographics that they
attract like i'm 81
male like women in general don't find my
my content appealing
i'm just saying like those are the
that's the data right those are the
stats
um but the thing is is that uh
by freeing myself of this i realize it
didn't impact my success at all
and other people growing with my you
know with me helping or without me
helping
didn't affect my success either but it
did massively affect my mental
well-being
um and so i guess there's two sides to
this message that you can take
one is if you were the you know the line
climbing up the mountain
um by all means stay hungry
as hell do whatever it takes for you to
stay motivated um
but i would say don't don't do anything
stupid
you know don't don't don't say anything
don't don't take massive you know
malicious attacks i didn't do that but
i'm just saying like
don't do that because you will end up
burning bridges
i've had a lot of people do that to me
and i'm sure bedros has had it too
and you know some of the guys have been
in the space for a long time have had
people do that
and what ends up happening is that you
just kind of burn your reputation
and you know what's going to happen is
somebody who's taking a massive
you know swipe at me um you know
they're going to want to do a deal with
someone else and that guy's going to
call me
and he's like what do you think about
this guy i'm like ah i think he's a
little bit i think he's naive i think
he's
i think he's noob i think he's small
bones i think he's an emotional person i
don't think he's able to restrain
himself i think he's very volatile i
wouldn't do business with him
if it were me um you can do whatever you
want and i would just be like this is my
experience with it
i would i don't touch people like that
with a 10 foot pole but do what you want
and usually when people hear that you
know from someone that they think is
less volatile they will usually heed
that advice and there's been probably a
lot of people who have taken attacks at
me who
somehow find things that just fall
through for them and that may or may not
have been as a result of
you know me but the point is that i
think that that anger
use it to fuel yourself but don't don't
use it to attack
it just doesn't end up going well and
also
people make associations with how they
feel about what you
say and so if you're always talking
negatively in general about other people
people will not remember who you were
talking about but they will remember how
you made them feel and they will
associate the negativity with you
and so that's something that um i
learned early on in like some of the
persuasion books and i was like oh okay
i need to watch out for that
and so it's hard for me especially
because i was like so angry when i was
younger
um that to not do that right and so
um that's that's one side of it right is
if you were if you were climbing the
mountain
um and i guess the message to the other
side is that like
it's just you're not gonna affect
anything like you're not gonna hurt
anyone by your success and that's like
that's probably the biggest message i
can give is like
you're not gonna hurt anyone like it's
not like you're not gonna hurt anyone
like when people make swipes at me it's
like it doesn't hurt me like it doesn't
affect me at all
um like it doesn't affect my business it
doesn't it just it just
affects you um and i'm only sharing this
because like it was something that i
think really hurt my mental well-being
when i was younger and i
and if i can provide value you know i
hope that
it doesn't affect those people if they
see this
um so anyways and maybe that's you you
know maybe it's maybe there's a
competitor in your space or maybe
there's
another you know another business down
the street that you're like screw this
guy blah blah blah
i can promise you you would make so much
more money if you guys just like talked
and
and shared like best practices because
it there's so
few markets where it's actually winner
take all
there's it's there's so few you know
what i mean that it actually works that
way it's a zero-sum game
the reality is that most businesses
can't even handle the amount of demand
that there is for the service and the
solution that they have
or the problem that they solve and the
other reality is that there's a lot of
people that like
things solved in different ways you know
if layla and i were entering the weight
loss space it's not like i have to start
attacking weight watchers you know what
i mean like there's just certain people
who are attracted to that type of
messaging
and if layla and i got into that space
we'd probably have a very different
angle brand message look and feel than
they would and we would attract
different types of people with different
values
and so it's there's a lot of room and
the ocean's very very big it's so much
bigger than everyone gives it credit for
um and that's i think i told a a story
recently about
a competitor quote competitor another
per another company in our space who's
who's doing this like the same amount as
i as we are
and they're not even they're not even
like marketing on facebook and i'm like
are you kidding me and they have an
entire outbound team and when i heard
that i was just like gosh
i just like i continue to have my mental
barriers stretched
around these concepts of like the game
is so big
and the only person you hurt when you
spit hate is yourself
um you you hurt your long-term prospects
because people at the top do talk
like it's it like there definitely is
like i think i heard andy fercello say
this it's like
everyone stops just like hanging out
like they're all just like most of us
know each other you know what i mean and
like
we text each other and hey how's this
working for you hey how's this where
like
there's no animosity like i'm friends
with a lot of people who are in the gym
space
who serve jim owners like i have no
malicious intention if someone's like
hey should i work with someone like give
them a shot you know what i mean like
everyone has a different way of doing
things um you know this is what ours
works well with and
if you like our style and you like you
know you like selling hard you like
going high ticket you like marketing
hard
uh you like focusing on metrics like
that's us you know what i mean like
there's
people who like more done for you like
that's cool too like there's guys who do
that really well
so anyways i uh i wanted to share this
with you because uh
ed inspired me uh to share this message
with you because
um if you you know if you are angry or
you've
you have this uh anger inside of
yourself i 100 get you i feel you
um but i would just say try and use it
to
spur yourself on do not use it to throw
shade
because it will not benefit your
well-being and it won't benefit your
long-term
success so anyways um i hope you found
that valuable
hope you enjoyed this um if you did
leave a like or comment or review or
just uh listen solemnly uh but anyways
hope you have an awesome day and a happy
saturday and i'll catch you guys soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you